[Music]
mai presentation I will show you
arenical perspective in the approach to
the February
Resistance is one of the morning caus of
mortality that according to Sum
estimates We will Rich about the million
That
Selective pressure Executive antibiotics
and Seals cosin the Murs of the Roses
Of charting The Use of The Same
antibiotic in acclutical setting
These of antibiotics
understetica in interactions between
humans Animals
prospective an International Travels il
facile saited of multidirect resistant
bacteria
decision alla marysey Is This is
Sampras in the pediatric population
first the island
Five percent of patiences e
lebot reapers of Fire per gli altri video
prescription in hour Emergency The
parking
a frequent related to the Barricades
S All around the world Rock samples
Stadium
especially and the case of inspirational
this is
Specialist clinical biologist Hospital
epidemiology and infection control Born
member but impruff the  Fight Against
Ro  bben Resistance
performance on capillary Blood sampling
Sick test and some pathogens antigent
testing like Streptococcus is
respirators
S
you from the table and thicknessing the
first for yours of life The Living Roots
of peyotes alla dosenvolding the Upper a
Lower respirators trekt
and Fashion and fiver of Now  Origin
Fever is one of the most Command House
of the partners of cases shoulders and
Fever with have
the clinical training
is you can Send
about sent of antibiotic harpers for
this of the respirator trekt in the
green books and the prescrivitevi
improvvise post specific
situations
understand of  Life
is a Reasons
Parlami del CBC William
if on the one Hand neutrophilia is offset
indicative of Material in Fashion
neutropenia or in lymphocytosis Can't
help Us students Five Byron Force while
ASL daughter who is a poet sty war
passitosis or allerge conditions
the limitation of the  CBC is letency at
the first changes addressable twerk the
Twenty Four hour after  the onset of
Fever every often Access passions with
Fever For much Last Time
Alfa
serie Active protecs is indicative or
bactualfaction with your is Another
probability but Wetter provider
that Fifty camperlitors
Today's conditions
our questions
Paul family
the clinical
Pictures
By Your Market
infection will be that of  the laboratory
patchspective  herpe Assistant We called out
about Now Nine Million of laboratories tes
borrier including morden One million of
stat test
dell'app provided to Forty percenting
Patience and Sixty percent to out passions
the alias have excellencer Total Quality
Health of doping
Allergy immunologists gastroenterologists
commentators
therapeutics monitoring and  drug  o
jinomics coso de laboratories optained the
accreditation of excellence in
nineteen ninety five the Iso
certifications Heaven and accreditation
accordi tutespecifica a Iso Ford
elaboratory in all lausen and sixteen
today
ed è topic of the infections the most
criticismsslissous in my opinion in the
Management oftest  clinical Process SIM
stupid Early die have noses in Order su
Avoid The evolution of sepsis and in
this setting It is welcode Concept that
a single by omarker mai provided
informations about and single Process and
not about Wolf Spectrum of the Complex
This is sepsis for this Reason
the most
the most efficient approach symptoms of the
approach combini several Marquez for
example Intesa stadi si reactive protein
guidance procalcitonin provider the
additions
provide
E veterature yes
es calculated as area and curve that The
accuracy providen Major mands of the
single baiomaker eswell
simili in cast iron reset Paper
demonstrate
germanscscribe display to discribe of
increas velio provided by the
combination of Side to chance Management
in comparison tozet of Italy
prescence
the combination of test providing and
Better a higher Avenue of the area under
Cube
[Musica]
dette combination is Critical and
additional Value in comparison DEA
closing provided by the Management  of
single e specific
is different is New approach is svin
discribed some Years Go
combining the results of several
proteins in two single predictive Score
si
very Complex study
that using several different a provage
Starting from Baia informatics screening
at
garantee a identification of several
combination of different proteins said
low and higher difference Action between
bacterial
infections and
between
several steps of the study ad Last of
the stadia de Final part of  the study
seventy pro  teins have be a identify
that Better discriminate between
bacterial viral in Fashion ed
led free protein are chosed ASD Better
combination and this protein are tral
tumor necrosis Factor protein
pet
appleley in viral infected passions
IP Ten and camocaine sito Caine Dead in
camotaxis AND
Sell Row inhibition  and The Walking no si
reactive protein That is a protein of a
cute Face with different roll in Giuly
in infection
infact ASL reporti di in this slide
significantly High Value of tral web
server in viral in fashions while Have
you can see
IP Ten
sip2 hallows
to  excuder the This is
differenceating infected from non infecting
patiences
show
in viral in Fashion and finally si
reactive protein That the demonstrade
higher vallium
in bacterial infection
Bat o particularly and optimal
performance SIM to be provided by the
computer all integration of the
concentrations of different proteins
identity
Material from viral in Fashion as we can
see this is  scortice Index originalting
for the measurement of Street protens a
low and Clear difference Action between
battery and materials
probability ofterial Material infections
and
very Lost
all'outprotein confident Signature of
viral in fashions in this population
Only the Third person
that not provide and Clear classification
Of The  Passion
but Maybe and
sagestion offshore
on this basis and Locked algorim generate
e range of score between or to one
hundred and according to the Sign Nature
Score Five Group a identity fired and in
particular
Justin and Nike probability of materials
is score between or to ten set  jazz e Nike
probability of Vaira in Fashion and the
intermediate Value Segesta e moderate
probabilities
in fashion is the score The very of
Score is between Ten to certified
the
Game of this Score of New approach
to impact On The Use
of antibiotics  di impact of the Sign
Nature on the meiose on all
time bayotics is Very interesting
becaus  and as we can see the additions of
the Index very you to Current clinical
practice reviews mean client in
particular the over youse or antabiotics
the this
Game of all clinical approach
the calculation Of The original Score
of Tree test
career
spread in laborathan in clinical
laboratories of  what caried out and several
relevant clinical to the third success a
Vitamin D tumol markers own site
Nine sonson and usin this platform di
platform It is possible to Major Teaser
protein
ben che tu e calculate the Indes e Net
Score That is the sig Nature from
immunologica  al Point of View
and
every described of trip proteins
combining the
Management to produce the Index of the
score are tral
tumor necrosis Factor related
Invisible
Teddy is Red is an protein member of
tumor necrosis X Factor Family
implicated in
programma il
Redmond ratings
to the viralfaction
the  IP Ten
the epiten is
camochino implicated in
serbo inhibition chemotaxis and in
nate and adapti  ve in una Response buy
activation o t-line fonsight and the al
Direction in Expression leves haral
associateslatori di Sisa include
infections This is and finally si
reactive protein
cute Face protein maestra Release in
Response 2 Pro inflammatory stimuli
basta Dead have different roll
intishing ingest in  Fashion or other inflation
Process
the Finals is a Bing Score That's Jet if
Lower there certificare from High to
moderate probability of viral in Fashion
if higher Den Sixty Five from High too
moderate of Activision
wireless between sincero
classification or Messenger
Furthermore you
evaluette the additive Value of  this New
Score or the additional
clinical information provided in Howard
University Hospital in collaboration Win
pediatric Emergency thepartment with
carried out first application on Forty
specials eigin Seven monts to Tai Years
sia Smith & to the Hospital We Fever
non morden 7 Day from the Blood  drawing
and inclusive binder this is exactly the
sit  o in oxidative protein
bewerbein hour study cady and out on
residue samples
between Paget included
in about twenty seven Patience Wear
monitored with procalcitonina deadmin
about seventy five specimens of the day
Arnold
standard is the Blood col culture caried
out in about Fifty percent of the
pacient that  are in antibaiotic
treatment in
about forte eight per semper
technique at Point of View
the measurement of Score and svinca Lied
out in Batch
and
Bang
of you di reagence
characterized by Same Lot for all test
while
calibrators and
Material for analytica alquality
Check specific Forfour test
and final de results is the scorie Index
even if the instrument provider the Value
of Each protein the final Reset sul be
Only the scores
of analytical performance considering
the imprecision at the final cut off
Show satispactory and a The plate
coefficiente tovagliation from the bubble
Point of View  we say Quality
specifications That
Should Be
evaluated Before  The introduction in
clinical practice and the expected
range expected Score according to the
manufactus sul B between na ninety to
one hundred
saging
probability of activial in Fashion
between o to ten High probability oval
in Fashion and the Value between
Justin and mode update probability of
bacterial  infection
in population stadied here Home in strong
and percent
is past Justin and Nike probably
probability of Activision
in certain percent of patiences
youbserve and very you of score between or
to forth meanings Lower then that
expected according to the manufactores
on management
in certain per Center Hours  Core is about
between or to for and sagest e Nike
probability of viral in Fashion and in
hour population only sevent Point Five
percent The Score providers
Hallo and Clear classification but is
equivocal Tiz means that free passions
are not classified By The Score
Di Maio pignon The  Monster
relevants obtained is the High
difference in scorelio between
aid  c materials
the difference i sohigh That We not of
Survive in posation and so No
observe greysondetto not a low and
correct classification
about the agreement We procacitonina
consideri in o poi Five microgran
forliter the
decisional level
serva
ennagrimente in certi Seven percent of
Patience
where the  scores e Nike probability of
bacterial infection Ending to point file
percent of Passion in widget The Score
sagesta e moderate probability of
factivity all infection
globaly in in More than Forty percent of
Passion
youtuber and procalcitonin
in disgroup of Patience
David agreement in
total is related to Five  fascias in
Where your
Season in Lower Den or Point Five but all
passions are bacterial in Fashion
because Black culture is positive So
we
in aula opinion
Maybe
related to the timing of Blood sampling
for procacitoning because it is welcode
progressive have a Release kayneted that
kinetic that
reviews  de velio Within normal range
test plus Days Act Start  Of The Simpson
Sting
del Real vallium Of The Score is in our
opinion the ability to excluded
with higher serpenti de bacted in
Fashion with Hide significas Because the
negative predictive velio is about 99
negative predictivation negative
foreseen vallis that one Pieces and vairas
alta dei cambi ninety  Nine percents That
the device
il correct and the Day not
Treat the Patience With anti-haiotics or
witholder antibiotic treatment if all
Ready Start and Tears There is the
really
important Point of the of the new Score
and the new test
Enna in National il nour opinion
opinion e National relevant very you Of
The Score
in comparisons
is that differently from procacitonin
de After Three Days provider negative
results weekend
in Howard Experience the Value of Score
es we can serious main
eleveited anti Seven Days provai di
gegen
informations Heaven Heaven impensions
unmited later from  the onset of the
disease
informations proved by the scores
Seven Days of th  e Start Of The Simpsons
Indeed
the Release carinetics of the biomakers
additional Value because
the Knowledge of the carimetic Release
After simulation My helloto declination
tu Adobe
algorithm and menturement more accurate
Ford specific pacient
according to the caineth Release e He's
May provider
sommelimitation in the air noses  and
deck School That maintain the information
a until Seven Day make provide and
National Value uso in pescet that are
admitted later after the Start Of The
Simpsons
In conclusion
about this New Opportunity and New
approach
The relevant
additional very You is Red
prochas to deference shate batterial
from viralgan fashions you
optimized Therapy ed in
particular Professional Point of View of
Opportunity più provider è in
information and relevant information in
very short Time Thirty Five minute
Thanks to the application of
several test 2 8 MTB platform tetta
eight e night Fruit and a low e  quick
clinical decision but in the hospital
if  tting
and a fally Automation testing in
Addiction a siur standard dice
results the other
protesting absurde fishency of the laboratories tu support de
early treatment decision and this New
Technology
Laboratory Point of
View
anytime When a New test All you algorithm
es bintur posed
nes se siamo tu depakin
connected Thank you
Thank you thurs
presentations of
infections in Adult ed impedì
clinical Sant
written
in particular
the Everything is between or to Sing Star
Wars The IP Ten to Pit is about twelve
Hours and the Pick tu crp to the time to
it was
painted you made
Fifty hours and One single Score asciured
best day  of
Seven Days
of Simpson
[Music]
from My presentation The Score is
a ebel tu accurate differentiation
between
bactirial and viral infection batoso Ed
Edd of Score messagegest and
information e byte possible code
infection of the Patience